-Oh, it's good
to see you, buddy.
-It's been a long time
since you've been by the show.
I'm happy to see you.
-It's great to see you, too.
But I love your beard.
-You like it?
-Yeah.
I think it really suits you,
and I dig it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Coming from you,
I appreciate it,
'cause I want to
talk about your --
You have a great mustache
in this movie.
-[ Laughs ] Yes.
-Look at this.
Talk about facial hair.
I mean, look at that.
-Yeah.
-That's a real one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ah, It was actually
fun to grow.
The director looked to me
on the first day,
he goes, "That's real?"
Yeah,
-Yeah, exactly.
-He was even --
-That's when you know it's good.
When somebody goes
"That's not real, right?"
-Yeah.
People with real beards
look at me,
They go, "Nice try, Jimmy."
Yeah, you're going for it.
I congratulate you, by the way.
Last time --
Since last time I saw you,
you won an Emmy
for "Down to Earth."
-Right.
-Your show on Netflix.
-Thanks, man. Thank you.
They love it.
Here's one of the reasons
I love you.
You're very talented.
You can do everything.
But you're very adventurous.
When you do these things,
You do stuff that
I wouldn't find fun at all.
But I like watching you do it
because it's exciting.
You like swimming with
crocodiles and stuff like that
and bungee jumping.
-Yep.
Stuff that -- I couldn't do
any of that stuff.
-Yeah, I mean, it all kind of
makes you nervous
before you do it.
-Is there anything
you wouldn't do?
-You know, I guess.
On swimming with sharks.
I did swim with tiger sharks
out in Hawaii,
and I love the people
that I went with,
but they invited me to go free
diving with Great White sharks,
and I just -- I was like,
why on earth would I do that?
That's just asking for it.
-Oh, good.
So I drew the line
-I'm so happy you drew the line!
Yeah, you're like, hey,
I'm an American treasure.
I'm Zac Efron.
I'm not doing this.
-Yeah.
There's a big downside.
I didn't want to.
That'd be a disappointing
way to go.
-Can I ask you about --
There's a rumor --
There's some casting calls
in the Internet.
Marvels looking
for a Zac Efron type.
-Really?
Wow, they could just call me.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah, I know.
I was going to say..
if you don't want to do it.
And then I thought
it'd be funny.
Seth Rogen, who we love,
tweeted out.
"Crap, I was gonna submit myself
for the Zac Efron type."
-[ Laughs ]
That's hilarious
-Isn't that funny
that he would do it?
-That's really funny, yeah.
-Could Seth play you
a Zac Efron type, you think?
Seth? I think, yeah.
Seth could do it,
If anybody could.
He would -- I would cast Seth
in anything over me, so...
-Yeah.
Yeah.
-Have you been
ever approached by Marvel?
It was just -- That was funny.
They were saying
a Zac Efron type, but you...
There was a rumor that
you were going to be
Wolverine at one point.
-Really? Dang.
-Yes! The Internet.
-I don't know.
-The people want this.
-I think Hugh's still doing
that pretty well.
I got to give it to him.
-Yeah, but you know Hugh.
You were in
"The Greatest Showman."
-Yeah, you're right.
But that was a different movie
with musical.
He'll let you do it.
-Okay, yeah.
Yeah, he's -- you know him?
He's a good guy.
-Yeah, I guess I had my foot
in the door on that one.
-I should go talk to him.
-Why not be Wolverine?
I would love to see you
as Wolverine.
I can see it.
-Yeah,
I would get a beard like yours.
-Yes!
I'll give you my beard.
I'll shave it off
and you can have my...
-All right.
-...clippings.
-If it happens.
-Let's talk about it.
Yeah, all right.
Let's talk
about your movie,
"The Greatest Beer Run Ever."
This is a true story?
And I almost can't believe
that it is a true story.
-Yeah, it's really wild, man.
So it all really happens.
Chickie Donohue is this guy
lived in a small town
in Inwood, New York,
when he was younger,
and all of his friends
were all fighting in Vietnam,
and he was just
sort of stuck at home
and he felt really powerless
to help them.
And simultaneously
there was a lot of bad press
coming through about Vietnam
and sort of the
anti-war movement.
And he just wanted to show
some support for his friends.
So he decided to get
a duffel bag full of beer
and actually go
to the Vietnam front line
and deliver each of
his enlisted friends a beer
just to say thank you.
-That's the craziest thing ever.
It's a real story.
And he's a real person.
-Yes.
-Here he is.
-It really happened.
-Here's you and Chickie
right here.
-Yeah. And it gets
a lot crazier than that,
as you can imagine.
He gets into some high jinks.
-Oh, my gosh. And it's directed
by the great Peter Farrelly.
-Yeah, Pete Ferrell's in it.
I mean, war is pretty sensitive
subject matter, you know,
It's like we took it
really seriously,
and Pete has this amazing way
of going through
really kind of tough,
you know, situations and sort
of serious subject matter
with this amazing
underlying humor.
-It's kind of unbelievable.
When you watch,
you go like, wait, someone
actually did this.
He went to Vietnam and he's
giving beers to his buddies.
You're like, this can't be real.
-I know. I kept like I was
reading the script.
I was like, "what the [ Bleep ]"
It was Bill Murray and Russell
and Russell Crowe.
-Yeah.
I mean, doing a movie with Bill
Murray and Russell Crowe,
how fun was that?
-It doesn't really get better
than that, man.
-It really doesn't, right?
-Yeah, I like both of those guys
for different reasons.
They're huge heroes of mine.
But Bill Murray,
when he was on set,
I just I remember
just thinking to myself,
I was like, I don't know
what's better than this.
-How about Russell.
-And Russell's very,
very similar experience.
Russell came into the movie
sort of toward the end
of the Vietnam section,
which we were shooting
in Thailand,
and he has
a pretty important role.
He plays this, like,
war photographer
that looks after Chickie
while he's there
on this really dumb mission.
And so a lot of the scenes
that he's in are sort of action
were running through Thailand,
explosions, just heavy drama,
a lot of, you know, destruction
and stuff like that.
And we -- he came in
just so prepared.
He knows so much
about this craft
that, like,
he could be directing it.
He directs a lot of stuff.
-Of course.
-But he also knows acting
so well,
you just want to be next to him.
-I know you're good,
but you ask him for advice
when you're doing a scene?
Do you go, like, hey,
would you do this?
-Yes, a lot.
You can't help it,
I mean, he's Russell Crowe.
He's like the best actor
that's ever lived.
So I'm constantly
looking at him like.
-Was that good?
-Is that all right?
-Yeah, exactly.
-How was that?
There was one scene that we had.
It was kind of a monologue
that my character has
just, like, a memory,
and he's kind of going into it,
you know, these old thoughts.
And, and this was
like four days into the shoot.
So I had gotten to know
Russell pretty well.
-Yeah.
-We were friends at this point,
and I did it once,
and I kind of looked
at him like,
"Anything you can fix?"
And he's like,
No, no, it's good.
Did another take,
and it was like,
"Anything?
Like, you can tell me?"
And he's like,
No, no, it's good.
Did one more and I went,
"Come on, give me som--"
And he goes.
"Okay, stop moving your
[ Bleep ] hands.
[ Laughter ]
And I was like, "Oh, really?"
And I never thought back
to the past takes.
And I was going like,
I thought this was a part
of my New York character.
I was just going like.
Yeah. Like, this is how I feel
and all these things and ahh.
Like that.
-Stop moving your hands.
-And he said that
and I was like, I took it.
-Wow.
-I was cracking up.
It was the best note ever.
The next one, I literally
just locked my hands
in my waist.
Like, just right here.
Just wouldn't let him go.
And we did one more take.
And after that,
everybody was like,
"Yes! We got it!
We got it!
-And he's like,
"You got it, kid."
-Russell was just like,
"There you go, kid."
-"Here you go, kid."
-So that's the kind of guy --
-It's a fantastic film.
And of course, Peter Farrelly
just coming off his Oscar win.
-Yep, yep.
-This is it.
You got to check out this movie.
-And you know, you know,
you worked back on --
"Fever Pitch"
with the Farrelly brothers.
Unreal. He told me to say
hello to you, man.
-He's the greatest, greatest.
I loved both of you guys.
-He is. Honestly, the best.
You guys gotta check this out.
Here's a clip.
Here's Zac Efron in
"The Greatest Beer Run Ever."
Take a look.
[ Gun fire ]
[ Breathing heavily ]
-You wanted to see me Sarge?
-No.
-Ta-da!
[ Laughter ]
-Chickie?
What are you doing here?
-I brung you beer.
[ Laughter ]
-Who -- Who are you with?
-I'm with you.
-Seriously, Chickie.
What the hell
are you doing here?
Really?
-Me and all the fellows
we're sitting around.
talking about what we could do
to bring your spirits up.
But then, Bang! It hit us.
Bring you a beer.
So I brought you a beer.
-You dumb [ No audio ]
-What?
-You just got me killed
out there!
-That's what I'm talking about.
Come on, bud.
Zac Efron, everybody.
"The Greatest Beer Run Ever"
is streaming now on Apple TV.
Plus, and in select theaters.
We'll be right back
with Debbie Harry.